it was another day of some pretty
intense questioning for the Justice
Department inspector general today at
issue
what part politics and Prejudice played
in the FBI's investigation of the
Hillary Clinton email scandal and by
extension the ongoing probe into Russia
election interference chief intelligence
correspondent Catherine Herridge is
watching it all here from Capitol Hill
they prejudge the outcome of the Hillary
Clinton investigation before the
investigation ended and these exact same
FBI agents and attorneys prejudge the
outcome of the Russia investigation
before it even began during a second day
of marathon testimony lawmakers pressed
Inspector General Michael E Horowitz
over what Republicans described as
political bias at the FBI impacting both
presidential campaigns they point to a
newly discovered August 2016 text
between FBI agent Peter struck an FBI
lawyer lisa page saying they would stop
Trump from being elected I wonder who
the wheels and the wheel stop it them
where the broader or a broader group
beyond that we have found three
additional FBI agents and some
transition to the Russia Special Counsel
investigation do they still work for
Mueller that's my understanding is no in
July 2016
agents struck also pivoted from the
Clinton emails to collusion do you
believe the political bias shown by this
text had an effect on the initiation of
the Russia investigation that's the
matter we've got under review
Horowitz testified a fourth forensic
review of the struck page FBI phones
uncovered the explosive text in May
Congress wasn't immediately notified we
sent it to the office of Deputy Attorney
General and from mr. Rosen Stein in his
office the point is when you did get it
mr. Rosen Stein decided we couldn't get
it until your report came out he sat on
it for a month of time another lawmaker
questioned why the report was silent on
allegations the Clinton's server may
have been hacked and the FBI failed to
follow up but that's not in your report
that's correct
the president weighed in when you read
that IG report about how she got away
with what she got away with it's a
disgrace after multiple reviews and an
FBI
investigation Democrats playing former
director james comey and accused
Republicans of refusing to acknowledge
that a Clinton prosecution was never
justified or they're howling about lock
her up with bogus it was baseless it was
unsubstantiated James Comey decided to
play judge jury and executioner and
October 28th he executed the Hillary
Clinton campaign the hearing concluded
after six and a half hours of testimony
with headlines in the final minutes
Specter general Horowitz confirmed that
he's following up on allegations that
FBI interviews summer is known as 302s
were altered Brett Catherine there's
also some late news this afternoon on
FBI agent Peter struck what did we learn
there well in a statement a Struck's
attorney confirmed to fox news that his
client has been fully cooperating with
an internal FBI review which included
recently being escorted from the FBI
building the statement also said at
least for now struck remains an FBI
employee Brett okay Catherine thank you